there is
an article that came out yesterday that
i was pretty convinced was the babylon b
and but it's not it's not the babylonia
this this article came from the texas
tribune
left out of the conversation transgender
texans feel the impact of states
restrictive abortion law
the transgenders are left out of the
conversation
now that they can't kill their kids the
men
the transgender men
cannot get
abortions while texas's controversial
abortion law strictly refers to women in
its phrasing
it also limits access to the procedure
for transgender and non-binary people
who are able to become pregnant
right it refers to women in the in the
law because there are only men and women
and transgender and non-binary are just
completely made-up categories but
further by the way
i'm not sure if you've noticed this
about non-binary
but the idea of non-binary
is that
is that people should not just be put in
one of two categories right that's why
so it shouldn't be man or woman it
should just it should be non-binary
but
the problem with with that line of
thinking is that
some people are non-binary
and other people are binary
meaning that you have a new binary
there's no you can't escape the binary
there is there's this new binary which
is binary and non-binary and then within
the binary there's men and women and
then within the non-binary there are a
bunch of there are a bunch of different
confused things
[Music]
i remember last year about 18 months ago
during the
democrat presidential nomination contest
julian castro
not the strongest candidate for
president he was trying to make a splash
he was trying to run to the left of
everybody else he came out on a stage
and he called for abortion rights
for men
i don't believe only in reproductive
uh freedom i believe in reproductive
justice
and
you know what that means is that just
because a woman or let's also not forget
someone in the trans community a trans
female
is poor doesn't mean they shouldn't have
the right to exercise that right to
choose and so i absolutely would cover
the right to have an abortion
we all laughed at this
a year and a half ago in particular
because he said a trans female which
actually a trans female is
a dude who gets some plastic surgery to
look more like a woman so in that case
you know a dude can he doesn't have a
uterus he can't get an abortion anyway
can't he can't conceive or give birth so
we all we all made fun of that no one
took it seriously and now
now it is being taken seriously
okay and we all we thought it was the
craziest thing we ever heard now it is
being taken seriously and of course
it is the season of giving is also a
season of taking for cyber criminals
looking to cash in
some tips to help you stay safe while
shopping online include only visiting
secure sites and apps from retailers you
trust using a vpn instead of public
wi-fi
creating strong passwords and checking
your bank and credit accounts for fraud
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet in an instant a cyber
criminal could steal what's yours
sometimes even harm your finances your
credit your reputation good thing
there's lifelock lifelock helps detect a
wide range of identity threats such as
your social security number for sale on
the dark web
if they detect that your information has
potentially been compromised they will
send you an alert you have access to a
dedicated restoration specialist if you
become a victim no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can help protect what's yours with a
lifelock by norton join now and save up
to 25 off your first year by going to
lifelock.com
knowles canada wles that's lifelock.com
knowles for 25 off when julian castro
called for abortion rights for men and
everyone laughed
we all should have known that it was
going to it was going to become
[Music]
a more mainstream concept
we should and so you see this article
now in the texas tribune talking about
it and it's it you're going to hear
within five to ten years you're going to
hear regular ordinary conversations
about transgender abortion how trans men
need to have the right to kill babies
and you're probably going to hear some
squishy republicans say look okay i
s
i support abortion rights
for
uh women and transgender men and
non-binary people but i draw the line at
pansexuals
right because that's the thing that the
republicans always do is they just
defend whatever democrats defended 18
months ago
so it's good you're going to end up at
the point okay listen
i support look i of course believe that
marriage is between three men a goat and
an alien okay but i think that when you
add a dog into the picture that's too
much all right that's where i draw the
line okay so you're this because that's
that's the logic of this
the logic that the libs are foisting on
us that a lot of squishes have accepted
is that men and women
are not distinct categories that men can
be women women can be men there's really
no such thing as men and women and there
are 54 genders
in addition to men and women at least
also so you you don't it doesn't mean
anything
to say that only women can have
abortions well if that's true
then yeah we're going to be talking
about we're going to be talking about
the non-binary and the trans
abortions and and this that and the
other thing
[Music]
[Music]